I think a lot of Americans are fooled
because our police state doesn't come in
the usual kind of cartoon Colors by that
I mean Americans think well if it's a
where's the Revolutionary overthrow of
the government that say lennin did
where's the Stalin Overcoat where's the
Hitler mustache our police state is very
cunning and it marches behind the banner
of law saving democracy upholding Truth
by by prohibiting misinformation and
even affirming Liberty so it's a
disguised police state um and it uses a
lot of
camouflage I'm Dave Ruben we're here at
the local studios in Miami and joining
me is an author a podcast host and
creator of the new film police state Des
duza welcome back to the Ruben report
thank you good to be on I have to say
you've been on a couple times but this
is this is
particularly uh fitting I POS because
your last movie 2000 mules was the first
movie that we ever released in such a
way on locals I did create locals we are
here at the locals studio and now you're
doing the same thing with the new film
so this feels not only politically
obviously we've kind of come together in
a lot of ways but uh but technologically
and everything else so it's a a nice
moment for me personally I suppose you
know the um the release of mules on
locals was a kind of radical step
because
um my old distribution model was to put
the movie in the theater let it run for
3 or 4 weeks then there was typically a
two-month interval theaters would
control when you could release it in
digital uh and then you'd sell it on
Amazon Prime or iTunes so when uh locals
approached me and we talked about this
the idea of doing something totally
different and offering the film through
locals and making locals in effect into
a movie platform it was it was sort of a
wild idea but it turned out to be a
great idea it worked out okay if I'm not
mistaken I'm not pry to all the numbers
anymore but I think it did all right it
was it was awesome and it it convinced
us that that is the new way to do it and
so we're doing we're kind of replicating
the same distribution for the new film
and um I'm I don't know if excited is
the right word because as I've said
about this film is not a film I wanted
to make cuz I never wanted the country
to be in a spot where you need to make a
film like this yeah and frankly if IID
made this film even five years ago I
think people would be like is this a
film on North Korea denes or Iran or
China no it's a film about how a lot of
the elements of those unfree societies
are now visible in our own so I want to
get into obviously police state and and
what it's about and yes it does feel
like many of us who have warned about a
whole bunch of this kind of as I said to
Ben Shapiro on my live stream this
morning it feels like in some ways like
we failed like we were yelling about a
lot of this but maybe we didn't do
enough to stop some of it let's say but
before we dive into into that fully I
thought maybe we could just talk about
just generally what's going on in the
world at the moment because it is a
crazy world and uh what do you make of
sort of where we're at what's going on
obviously in the Middle East what
America's role is supposed to be I'm
just tossing a wide one at you we'll go
there well the um I think this the the
attack by Hamas and the fact that it was
not only missed by Israeli intelligence
which is something to examined within
Israel but clearly missed also by us
intelligence and now let's flash back to
post 911 when many people I mean me
included were like listen there's
something that's going on within Islam
you've got this emergence of this ra of
radical Islam uh and it has become uh
militant in a way that we haven't seen
before maybe it all started with the Ki
Revolution but you see this militancy
within the Shia and Sunni strains of
Islam both okay we got to give a lot of
these new surveillance Powers we need to
collapse some of the old distinctions
between intelligence gathering and let's
say criminal prosecution because we're
not just trying to wait for a crime and
then go chase who did it we're trying to
prevent a crime from occurring before it
does but we were warned even then and
this is a case where some of the
Libertarians the sort of the Rand Pauls
and Ron Pauls of the world were like
guys if you give this power to the
federal government they not only can but
they will abuse it right that that sort
of gets us to your movie but we right
yeah so that's one phase of the whole
thing I think that's really interesting
the other phase that interests me as
someone who's written about education
about the campus is how you have these
guys who have been delicate flowers on
the campus you know don't offend me
don't trigger me I can't hear an opinion
I disagree with microaggressions make
sure you get my pronouns right and then
when you get a mass attack with all this
these
atrocities they seem to be politically
okay with it uh they'll say well we're
not defending Hamas we're defending
Palestine but clearly they are okay with
in the name of decolonization and in the
name of resistance they tie their own
domestic causes in with the cause of
Hamas yeah do you see that that tiin and
how quickly BLM sort of flipped into
what I would argue is really a pramas
movement the the distinction I can't
make that distinction because I don't
see anyone on the ground making that
distinction right at these rallies you
don't see anyone out there going no no
I'm for Palestine I'm against Hamas it's
not no I mean look at the BLM could have
posted a Palestinian child with big eyes
but they posted the the Hamas terrorist
coming in on a glider so so what do you
make of how that has now been exported
into the United States and it does seem
you know we always use the word systemic
related to everything it does seem
systemic and that it doesn't seem
organic that these protests happen the
what some might call an Insurrection at
the capital in the last couple of days
ETA I mean I've been struck by the fact
uh that the left is a global move
movement the right is not a global
movement the right tends to be confined
within each country now there are some
links that are beginning to emerge
because people see The Echoes right I
mean you had this quote Insurrection on
January 6th we saw something almost
identical in Brazil right um when you
think about coid restrictions for
example restrictions on religious
liberty on right to assembly yes you saw
them in America but then hey they're in
Canada hey they're in Australia they're
in New Zealand they're all over Europe
so suddenly and I and I actually raised
this in the film I say wait police state
yes but police Planet maybe because now
you're beginning to see a global
movement pushing kind of in the same
direction I think that also applies to
the um to the sort of Hamas BLM Alliance
the left here draws energy from from
similar forces abroad and vice versa I
don't know if you saw the Hamas leader
he's like talking about George Floyd
yeah no it's incredible he said this is
our George Floyd moment right do you
think we have the right apparatus or the
right fortitude to fight this I mean it
it seems like things keep sliding
somewhat in the wrong direction I keep
telling people like I'm very bullish on
the State of Florida that's where I live
you're in Texas obviously some good
things are happening there but the
country as a whole seems very very
wounded at least with the leadership we
have right now and the agencies I think
there are two problems here one is that
the uh there are some things that can be
fought in an individual basis like
here's what I can do but there are other
things in the police state as one of
them it requires institutional
coordination the way you block a police
state is you have a Supreme Court ruling
that strikes down this nefarious
alliance between the government and the
digital platforms often Opera operating
by the way through intermediaries you
know nonprofit groups academics and so
on the courts need to do that uh and
then you need you know the Republican
Congress to do things and uh you need
Attorneys General to do things I mean it
would it would send a shock wave through
the Democrats if you had if you suddenly
had Republican Das in Texas in Florida
and elsewhere indicting major figures of
the democratic party for crimes that are
occurring in their states so legitimate
prosecutions but if none of those occur
so what would be a prosecution that well
let's take take an example I'm just
playing the game the Democrats play so
for example Texas there is open child
trafficking going on across the border
the Biden Administration is well aware
of it to them it's a casualty of what
they want to achieve which is they want
to bring all these people over here they
know that this our cartels they know
that these kids cuz a lot of these
adults come in with a kid you know
here's here's a dependent child but it's
not their kid and so the kid goes into
basically a child trafficking operation
because the child trafficking operations
volunteer to quote adopt these kids this
is by the way all in the movie and so
the Biden Administration is yeah that's
ugly stuff and we're not we don't intend
that but it's an acceptable consequence
of what you're doing well imagine for
example if the Texas Attorney General
and you can even do this in locally
indict mayorcas or or bring an
indictment for knowing participation in
criminal and illegal sex trafficking and
child trafficking so it's interesting
because it's one of the things that I've
been bringing up on the show a lot
lately which is that the Democrats seem
so negligent when it comes to the border
that it cannot be it can't be negligence
that it must be intentional that's
basically what you're saying I think now
we're getting into this weird spot with
Rashida Talib where it's almost like we
have a we have an agent in the
Democratic party how do you blend that
as someone that just made a movie called
police state out out this very week out
on locals and in theaters how do you
blend doing the right thing without then
becoming part of the police state where
you're taking out people who you know
maybe you disagree with no I mean I I
agree and I I don't think that the
advice that we should do exactly what
they do because if they do Lawless stuff
I'm not saying we should do Lawless
stuff but I'm saying that there is
something invertebrate about the
Republicans and and somewhat even the
conservatives which is when you say
things like I can't do what the other
side is doing I'm standing on principle
I'm better than that this is actually
the staple rhetoric of right the right
of
center that is dependent on a context
that um I think is no longer our context
so you know think of the think of the
movie uh you know Jimmy Stewart and The
Man Who Shot Liberty Balance and he's
this very uh straight laac lawyer yeah
and his basic idea is you know we have
to believe in the law we don't believe
in the law of the Jungle so I'm not
going to go get a gun I have a law book
and if something happens to me I'm going
to like call in the authorities report
it to the sheriff now if you're in a
small town with a decent sheriff and an
infrastructure of that that is the way
to go that's the way I want to live on
the other hand if you take a covered
wagon and go out west and you suddenly
realize that Outlaws have encircled your
Ranch and they've got all these long
guns and they want to burn your
homestead and rape your wife take your
kids and if you say I'm not going to go
for my rifle because you know I don't
want to be like them and you know I'm
I'm better than that I'm a man of
principle I mean you don't even know
what to say to such a person because
they have no appreciation of the gravity
of the situation and the fact that
you're in a combat zone and you need to
act at least start with the psychology
of that and then decide how you should
respond were you intentionally trying to
bring that to my first question about
Israel and Hamas because that's what you
basically explained right there we have
one side that's saying we have some
rules and you might not like the rules
that they're playing by but they're
saying we have some rules that have been
borne out of Western ideology and we
have another side saying we're going to
try to kill as many of you and as many
of us as possible actually at the same
time that that's a real problem I mean
with the Hamas thing is so creepy
because the reving in the massacre of
women and civilians you know there's
been a Trope in America for 30 years
about sort of I think the philosopher
Leo Strauss called it the reductio ad
hitlerum everything is linked to the
Nazis right and normally the problem
with that is that the Nazis are so much
worse that the analogy to Nazism always
seems like a little stretch but think
think about it the Nazis were very
careful to have their death camps not
the concentration camps which were labor
camps but the death camps outside of
Germany they were in the occupied
territories they were in Poland and
that's because the Nazis had to hide
those crimes because they couldn't say
we're gassing the Jews and were proud of
it they couldn't do that but the Hamas
does that Hamas basically goes we're
killing kids and look here we are and
there's a certain kind of triumphalism
about that that I think is so morally
unnerving that when I see people
defending it or defending the cause that
motivates it it's very discombobulating
so when you see the sort of chaos that
we're seeing right now these these
rallies the protests you know we're only
two three years out of coid Summer of
Love and all of the chaos related to
that um we need law enforcement to do
some things and yet you're making a
movie about the ever encroaching
movement or ever encroaching growth I
suppose of the security State well I
mean I mean we need law enforcement to
do the things that it was empowered to
do I mean this is a little bit like
sometimes when I talk police state I'll
have these Republicans this is like a
classic Republican Congressman responds
well dises we're supposed to be back the
blue now your you're saying the police
state and I'm like like of course I you
know there's no contradiction between
backing the blue and backing the cops
doing what cops are supposed to do and
similarly insisting that the FBI go
after the mafia and go after organized
crime and do the things that the FBI was
set up to do but you know I have to
explain in this movie what is going to
cause an FBI agent by and large a good
guy and in fact sometimes a right of
Center guy to kick into an apartment at
6:00 in the morning go find some
70-year-old grandmother like wrestler to
the ground you know put our twist arms
behind her back and put handcuffs pull
her down the the stairs if she won't go
willingly pull her into the street where
her neighbors come and the gaw at her I
mean how do you get a good guy to do a
bad thing I think that is key to
understand understanding the psychology
of a police state and that's what people
used to ask about the Nazis actually not
to do that ruum but I mean that was the
same question these weren't all bad
people five years before yeah and I I
specifically mention um you know Hannah
arent and Her idea about ikan from the
book ikan in Jerusalem that ikan was
yeah he was a Nazi but that wasn't what
motivated him he was sort of like I want
to be part of a really efficient system
I'm like a I'm an upand Comer I want to
I want to be recognized for my own
creative efforts and so I'll Ally with
this cause and I'll become a sort of
master builder of this cause and so this
was aren's famous phrase the banality of
evil because this guy was not all about
uh you know let's let's rid rid Europe
of the Jews he was ultimately an
opportunist and a social climber and I
think that is an important Insight you
need they're evil people and then you
have evil people who set up bureaucratic
mechanisms to get good people and and
and just ordinary people who want to get
ahead in life to to do those bad things
was the Genesis of this movie January
6th or I'm guessing you've been you've
obviously been kicking these ideas
around for quite some time but was that
really the the thing that got you to
make it I started out thinking or at the
reaction let's say to January well I
started out thinking that there is an
untold story about January 6th and I
think we actually have it in the movie
by that I mean I always like to not just
recycle what other people are saying but
break new ground in understanding event
and we can talk about that if you like
but but I started out saying I've got an
insight about January 6 let's do a movie
on that then I realized there are four
or five other the guys making a January
6 movie and so I pulled back and I
thought to myself there's a bigger story
here that connects to really all the
features of a police state because me
I'm a creature of the 1980s the Cold War
there are police states of course now
like North Korea China Iran and of
course the old Soviet Union so then I
said well what do those police states
have in common well they have Mass
surveillance of citizens they have
systematic censorship they have this
mind-numbing indoctrination and
propaganda in the schools and in the
media they tend to be one party states
which is to say not that they have no
elections but the elections are sort of
controlled so that the if there is an
opposition it's subordinate to the
regime um they criminalize dissent they
go after religious liberty they have
political prisoners and I go whoa all
these elements to one degree or another
I see here in America and it's a shock
for me because I'm an immigrant I mean
you know I've written books like what's
so great about America I've been very
much of a an American exceptionalist a
Rah American
triumphalist and yet that America is not
the America we're living in now so this
movie to that degree has a personal
Dimension it's like what happened to
those Liberties and the Bill of Rights
that were supposed to be
unalienable above political negotiation
not subject to majoritarian
overthrow uh suddenly all those rights
are in Jeopardy do you think our
institutions have enough of a sort of
self-correcting system within them to
fix some of this I mean it seems to me
right now if we didn't have a supreme
court that leans the way it does we
would be seriously seriously screwed and
as we're taping this right now the
Republicans can't even figure out a
speaker of the house like it could end
up being a Democrat that's how that's
how insane with a republican majority it
could end up a Democrat house you know
in essence controlled house it is it is
absolutely uh absolutely nuts now look
we're not a full-fledged police state
obviously if we were we wouldn't be
having this conversation and I wouldn't
be making this movie so when the jaws of
the police state snapshot I have Yan me
Park who's a North Korean Refugee she's
a friend of mine and you know Yan me
goes listen when when the jaws of the
police state are shut there's no time
that remains all you can do is run yeah
you know get out get your family out get
your money out but but we're not there
um now I think the reason our
institutions have proven so vulnerable
is is one because there have been these
sort of fear inducing events let's start
with 911 but then let's add co uh let's
even add January 6th because if you
think about it all of those were
pretexts for massive expansions of state
power and encroachments on Liberty that
would not otherwise have occurred you
can't tell Americans you can't go to a
church you can't go to a synagogue
unless you got it's a virus so you can't
do it for that reason and similarly I
think the idea that you can't talk about
eight subjects on social media it was
after January 6th that that became okay
to say and and YouTube is like proudly
listing all the things you can't talk
about um so I you could deny elections
let's say for four years before that
under Trump the second it went the other
way then it was it was it was restricted
exactly uh the other thing I want to say
is that I think a lot of Americans are
fooled because our police state doesn't
come in the usual kind of cartoon Colors
by that I mean Americans think well if
it's a where's the Revolutionary
overthrow of the government that say
Lenin did where's the Stylin Overcoat
where's the Hitler mustache our police
state is very cunning and it marches
behind the banner of law saving
democracy upholding Truth by by
prohibiting misinformation and even
affirming Liberty so it's a disguised
police state um and it uses a lot of
camouflage I mean a classic example of
this to me is fouchi you know if it was
a stalinist regime fouchy wouldn't need
to do any of this he wouldn't need to do
any excuses just like the ordinary goon
Falin when he comes to you and catches
you on the train he doesn't have to
explain to you why you're being arrested
you're on a list you resist They smash
you over the head that's the end of the
story no explanations necessary but what
fouchi does is and I think you know
again the human motives are really
interesting Here Comes Co and fouchi
goes oh crap you know I've been funding
this gain of function research it's in
collaboration with just this exact Wuhan
lab I need to figure out a way to throw
people off that sent otherwise it may be
blamed on me so what if I get some very
top-notch virologists and get them to
say independently that it was in a wet
market now fouchi realizes I have a a
weapon in my Arsenal I give all these
people money I fund most of them so let
me call up those guys put them up to the
idea of writing a paper they'll
understand it's tied to their federal
grants they will send the paper to me in
advance I will kind of review it
beforehand but then when it comes out I
will have a press conference and act
like I just dis a very reputable
academics have issued a paper and you
know so what this whole flim s like the
swampiest thing in swamp yeah yeah this
whole but what I'm saying is it's only
necessary because fouchi cannot openly
say uh what Stalin could have said which
is don't ask any questions this is our
official position and if you say
otherwise you'll find yourself in prison
so is the Hope then um I suppose without
giving away maybe some prescriptions at
the end of the movie is the Hope then
then that the system now because we have
so much information although it is they
are clamping down on information it's
not as easy to just black bag the guy
and and get them out of the system the
the basically is now seen more
right compared certainly to North Korea
or some of the other places you
mentioned absolutely I mean I think that
I mean there are ways of course in which
technology is is also hurting us uh but
it also offers counters to um as
interesting scene in the opening pages
of Soul n's Gulag where he talks about a
woman who goes into a market and her
friends tell her you're on a list you
need to leave now um and the woman goes
I'd rather go to my apartment and pack
of course she goes to her apartment
they're waiting for her there she's
arrested that's basically the end of it
for her and then Soldier needs comments
he goes we have a very big country had
she just gone straight to the train
station and gotten on a train she would
never have been heard from again she
would have disappeared in the vast
Soviet Union they'd never find her well
obviously today they would find her it's
a little different a little differents
exactly so that's a good to me
Illuminating example of how technology
can be part of the Weaponry of a of a
police state um but uh I think the power
of a film and this was also to some
degree true through of 2,000 mules when
you expose a system the system then has
to adapt it doesn't necessarily give up
on its objective but it can't do it that
way so for example in the 2022 election
there were all these Arizona Pat it's
like literally sitting at the drop boxes
with like beer and a camera and they're
like if the mules show up we're going to
record them there's no nothing illegal
in sitting by a Dropbox there's nothing
illegal in fact in in in putting
surveillance on a Dropbox because that's
actually called for in the election
rules and I think as a result the
Democrats they had to figure out a
different way so in Arizona they said
what if we have a glitch in all our
machines on Election Day and all these
dumb Republicans sort of voting early
are all going to show up on that one day
so if we can make it difficult that one
one day because of some accidental
glitches we will suppress the Republican
vote so my point is not that again not
that they gave up the scheme but they
had to do it a totally different way
similarly here I think with the police
state if you blow their cover and people
really understand how this is put
together and they also I also want to
convince people because there going to
be some guys who go to n well you know
I'm not Trump and I I didn't go in the
capital on January 6 and fight with the
cops and I pay my taxes so they're not
going to come for me so I I need to show
I do a lot of ordinary guys in the movie
they're just going about their life
they're not they didn't go in the
capital they're just participating in
Civic life or they're they're upset with
what their kid is learning in school
sure and or that they don't want their
kid to be a girl who's a boy like some
basic stuff exactly and then suddenly
you know the hot breath of the police
state or you know what Orwell calls the
boot stamping on the human face and
they're like whoo and and I by showing a
lot of those people and then not only in
some cases I actually have their their
body the body cam footage and all that
stuff it's all in the movie In some
cases I recreate it and so the beauty of
a film is it's it's show not tell so you
you give people an experience of
something that otherwise they might be
in somewhat denial about I want to talk
a little bit since you mentioned 2000 Ms
obviously in the election I I started
asking you something right before we
started but I think it's worth bringing
up and it and it fits in the context of
this which is one of my issues with
Trump who I supported obviously and I
like a lot and I will gladly vote for
him if he's the nominee obviously I I
think STIs at the moment is the best you
actually we should get into you you gave
a great explanation of the difference
between the two of them we can do that
in a second but one of my criticisms or
or thoughts of why it might not work for
Trump is that if he believes they stole
it from him which is what he believes
you made a movie about it then unless he
has done the leg work to ensure that
they will not do it again I don't see
how it makes sense to even be running to
a certain extent now I've heard some
what I hear people saying is Well he'll
overwhelm the system this time this time
the Biden is so bad and he's a Walking
Corpse and they'll just it will be a 10
million you know spread on this thing
and they won't be able to steal it that
just does that's completely antithetical
to what you just said there that
basically the system always stays in
front sort of yeah what would your
counterargument I mean if I was sort of
advocate for Trump which I'm not I would
say um a couple things um one is that um
one is that the peculiar circumstances
of coid allowed a complete promiscuous
sort of discarding of the rules of the
election so for example the rules say
that election dropboxes have to be
surveilled it's in the in the rules and
yet when we did 2,000 mules we looked at
five states uh there were whole states
that had no surveillance at all and
they're just like we were we were coid
we didn't get around to it and the
courts were like oh I guess coid you
know so they they gave them a pass and
as you lay out in the movie you I mean
it's pretty great in a time of coid to
have people dropping off things at 4:00
a.m. with cameras that you can't really
see with masks on their face I mean the
mask kind of helped the mask the mask
also helped the other thing is the so so
I think what happened in in 2020 was
that the election
was stolen in two ways uh one was the
the unleveling of the playing field and
this really everyone agrees with in
other words the Zuckerberg intervention
of money the um the fact that the mail
and dropboxes were heavily concentrated
in Democratic areas the fact that um
leftwing uh legal groups you know filed
claims uh and got settlements out of
left-wing um uh election officials and
and secretaries of State who basically
went you're suing me for us not to clean
up our voter roles okay we won't clean
up our voter roles in a settlement all
of this all of these Shenanigans went on
and they were legal but legal in the
sense that they were well they weren't
legal but they were allowed by courts
and they were legal in that sense the
other thing was the mule operation which
was taking advantage of the what I just
said to recognize that when you have bad
voter roles uh again you know sometimes
people didn't quite get 2,000 meals it's
not that the Democrats were quote
running off ballots on a on a machine
and copying ballots that when you have
bad voter roles it's not difficult to
come up with absentee ballots that are
the guy exists but he doesn't live in
Georgia anymore so without though
without fully Rel litigating that what
would would you if if you were sitting
with Trump what would you say to him
regarding why wouldn't they do it again
I would simp I would simply say that the
Republican National Committee with a
impressive battery of lawyers needs to
go state by state and insist and this is
especially true in all the swing States
24-hour surveillance on all the
dropboxes that alone that alone will
kill the problem of mules because
because you have the surveillance I mean
the simple truth of it is with with cell
phone geot tracking and surveillance you
can bust that operation I mean we busted
it to a degree but law enforcement could
have busted It Wide Open do you have any
reason to think that he's done that or
that the RNC has done that I I actually
don't know and In fairness In fairness
it's not because it's In fairness it's
because and there are people who come to
me and say Danes what are you doing to
fix voter fraud and I go well listen my
job is done I made a movie and the point
of the movie is to hand off to you guys
there are organizations that deal with
this in a day in and day out and so in a
sense I I've not fallen behind on that
topic as I pivoted to to the topic of
the police state I have reason to
believe that they're now aware of it
they've certainly got the team they've
raised a lot of money on this issue um
there are groups like TR the vote that
do this sort of day in and day out so
I'm hopeful that it's going to be better
but you know am I naive enough to think
that they fixed it all no I think
knowing just the GOP I mean I've lived
with the GOP for 30 years they're
probably doing a half ass job and so I'm
going to consider the problem like half
fixed right which fix probably doesn't
do it and by the way DeSantis could be
the nominee and they would still have
those problems the the thing that I
would say would be different in that
regard is sort of an offshoot of what
you said on Tim Po's podcast a week or
two ago which I thought was quite good
his operational efficiency I think would
start lending itself to to taking care
of some of that stuff C can actually can
you just uh point I was making was on
you talking Trump that was on with an
Coulter and you know uh and an was sort
of railing about Trump and and she was a
huge Trump person at one point she was
she was the first one that said it's G
to happen she was a huge trumpster I
mean I think she even wrote a book which
I wouldn't put you know in Trump we
trust you know anyway um and I I was
making the point I said look uh
regardless of whether you think Trump
should be the nominee we the real
question to ask is is if DeSantis is so
manifestly Superior in the ways that you
describe why is Trump leading
overwhelmingly in other words what is it
that the Republican base thinks about
Trump that you're missing and and I
think the answer very simply is the
Republican PA base thinks that Trump won
the 2020 election and and for that
reason alone the Republican base thinks
this guy deserves another shot because
he is the the legitimate winner of the
last one so the idea of saying okay well
too bad for him let's just give it to
someone else there's a reluctance to go
there but the second point I made is is
just a political point and I and I this
is something I noticed going back to the
days of Reagan there are some
politicians who have this kind of Larger
than Life quality which is very evident
I mean when we if you in a large
Ballroom of a thousand people and Reagan
walked in the room it was unbelievable
to see everything go silent every head
turned and and even Reagan I noticed I
mean this is maybe part of his Hollywood
he's very aware of this and he is very
careful he you know just the way he held
himself the way he cocked his head he
knew that he was under sort of
observation now there are other people
who are really good guys and I saw this
with a lot of Reagan ites who were sort
of they were essentially clones of
Reagan on policy issues but they just
didn't have that janas quad they just
didn't have that star quality they just
didn't have that it that's it and so
with this so my point to an was that
sort of you know if you could combine
the kind of Charisma of trump with the
ruthless operational efficiency of
disantis that's kind of what I think
everyone is looking for yeah well that's
why to me regardless of who I want to be
the nom it's been so disappointing
because it's like man the all the pieces
are here we could have the most United
party exactly probably well certainly in
my lifetime or maybe maybe not since
Reagan Reagan re-election or something
that I mean I'm not advising Trump but
if I were I'd be like listen you know
the first thing to do and this is
actually what a big man does is call up
to santis and sit sit down and say you
know what we would make an unbelievable
team and um not to mention the fact that
you know how do you when you think about
people who say things like let's defund
the FBI let's take down the FBI I say to
myself well we need an FBI I mean we
need a law enforcement agency that goes
out to organize crime um the FBI does a
lot of good things so how do you sort of
fix the FBI it's not a simple matter of
I'm going to fire the Christopher Ray
and put in a new guy somebody needs to
burrow into the FBI and root out the bad
guys because there's a corrupt structure
of incentives that goes all the way down
that makes even good people act badly
and so you need a bureaucratic infighter
to do that so imagine if Trump were to
say to DeSantis you are my man to drain
the swamp but I need you to go into the
swamp uh and you're the guy to do it and
uh and clean it up because I that's
actually not my temperament I have the
intention and I now have of course the
determination but see this is this is a
mature politics and this is what a
mature party would do but the fact that
it's not happening it doesn't mean to me
won't happen but you I share your you
know exasperation that it doesn't seem
to be headed in that direction right you
could even take a guy like RFK to me and
send him to go fix the agencies even
though I have big political
disagreements with him it's like that's
a guy who's fighting a lot of the same
battles that you're talking about when
it came to coid overreach and everything
else like he's a lawyer he seems to get
it like send him in I mean think think
of the value it would be to Trump to
find a prominent Democrat and basically
say this guy is gonna be like my Zar on
coid and free speech and having a
Democrat I mean there's a strategic
value to all this which you know you
think our side would understand by now
um but um uh so this is a broader
frustration I have and and I think if
there's one message I have implicit in
police state it's not in the movie but
it's it I think it's the clear take-home
value of the movie is that the spine of
the Republicans needs to be stiffened
and Republicans also need to fight
smarter because they um uh they're we're
up against something I don't know an
alternative to the Republican party and
I don't really sympathize with people
who talk about a third party or we need
some other because this is the mechanism
we have and uh and it's a mechanism with
a great history and it's one that could
be very effective if we use the power
Just the power that we already have
right now yeah do you sometimes think
and again as a guy that lives in Texas
and be here in Florida that the the
micro version of it the experiment of
America the state part of it will work
we have an incredibly powerful Republic
looking party here we we basically don't
have a Democrat Party anymore in Florida
um you're not quite at that level in
Texas but like you've got a functional
state that it'll just work in some
places and it won't work in others but
of course that ever
encroachment I mean I think that's right
I I I do think that the decentralization
of power is an important theme for us
because we you know I think Hayek used
the phrase a framework of competing
Utopia Hey listen you know what you have
a bunch of states and the 50 states are
doing a lot of different things some are
going to work and some aren't to me
what's interesting about the Democrats
is that they are showing creatively
imaginative ways to ruin places in
different ways so I just saw something
very amusing about the the San Francisco
model versus the Chicago model so the
San Francisco model is that you don't
have driveby shootings where people you
have a massive homicide rate the San
Francisco model is let us have a
lowgrade criminality but spread it
throughout the city you cannot Escape it
you know what I mean it's everywhere
yeah some psycho homeless guy is going
to come up to you and punch you or grab
a chicken wing off your plate um but it
allows the Liberals to say well listen
you know I'm being compassionate and the
guys has issues now the Chicago model is
that you have just like open gunfire but
interestingly it's not all over Chicago
it's in it's in the black areas it's in
the baros it's in certain pockets and so
the progressive can say well you know
it's not affecting me it's not in my
neighborhood Bam Bam Bam you know
somebody else is getting killed so it it
creat happening at their universities
now except it's exactly so it they even
ultimately suffer the creep um look
Texas is very interesting because Texas
was starting to Trend a little bit more
purple but I think the Hispanics will
save Texas believe it or not the real
Grand Valley is just moving dramatically
we supported a candidate down there Myra
Flores and she got like 46% I mean she's
in Striking Distance and with the trend
her way you know she has a good shot the
next if I'm not mistaken she was the
first um Republican that Elon Musk ever
voted for in his life I think that's
right I think that's right and tell you
she lost but not by a lot and of course
uh next door um so out of three we got
one out of three but I I predict in 10
years we'll get three out of three in in
those in the in the blue this is the
deep blue part of Texas all right I got
I got one more for you then for a guy
that made a movie called police state
and uh that that talks about
controversial stuff and you know you've
been attempted cancelled a hundred times
and you do a movie about election uh you
know questions last time and people
aren't happy about that and everything
else this one seems a little more close
to that edge I mean how do you factor
that into your life as as a as a human
being as a father and new grandfather
and everything else you know I I think I
this is a lesson I learned from my
campaign Finance case with the Obama
Administration and I and I'll admit that
you've been doing this a long time and
you've paid the price literally in I
mean even though that you know people
look back and they go well dush you're
one of the first or the political
prisoners and so on but I didn't see it
that way I saw it as a one-off I thought
look I made this film on Obama he's a
bit of a vindictive narcissist and and
and so he just put his attack dog Eric
Holder go get that guy I didn't see it
as a precursor to cter page Papadopoulos
Michael Flynn of course now now Trump uh
the escalation under Biden I think has
taken me by surprise the rapidity of it
uh and also the comprehensiveness of it
because in some ways people talk about
you know a deep State I don't like to
use that phrase that much because to me
part of the police state is in the open
some of it is hidden to be sure but some
of it even outside the government it
almost is reminiscent Orwell in 1984
talks about the fact that big brother
has an inner party and an outer party so
the inner party are the guys who are
behind closed doors but the outer party
is the propaganda of the media it's the
education system I mean we can go on
YouTube and read all the 17 topics we
can't talk about that's not hidden
that's not deep that's just in the open
and and and what amazes me is the way
that censorship you know this kind how
it works an academic will will make and
these academics have nothing better to
do so they're like we are students of
disinformation you know we've compiled
the 500 most dangerous purveyors of
misinformation I'm always on those list
you you and I have the list so then what
happens is that the Biden regime picks
it up and they go all right Dave ruin
has been circulating lies about coid
we'll send his name to the CDC dases has
been Circ culating election lies we'll
send that to cisa the cyber security
infrastru and so you've got like 40
agencies involved they're compiling
lists but then they know if we go to the
digital platforms directly we could get
busted by the Supreme Court let's bring
in a middleman let's go to the Stanford
internet Observatory let's go to the
verality project we hand off to them
they then become our ciers they go to
the digital platforms the digital
platforms then bring out the hatchet and
then the media cheers so I mean look
look who's involved Academia the media
the digital platforms the government I
mean you've got multiple organs of
society working in a sort of
coordination it's it's a very scary
thing it means that even if you win the
election that begins to fix the problem
but by no means doesn't fix it I don't
know that I fully got my answer though
which was about you personally just like
oh me uh yeah I mean I I basically
learned from my case that um that you
are safest paradoxically on the front
line because if I'm out there making a
movie
uh and of course I now I'm much more
careful than I was 10 years ago and kind
of watching my back I got some really
good advice from the former um
lieutenant governor of Texas David duur
he goes denesh do not make a move
without a lawyer signing off on it
legally and do not make a move
financially without an reputable
accounting firm saying do this because
if you do those two things it's going to
be very hard for them to get you I
followed the advice of my lawyer I
followed the advice of my accountant so
they can try to say well you still owe
us money but they can't say that you're
guilty of a criminal act because you
went through you took professional
advice and followed it so anyway my
point is I I live my life now according
to these sort of guard rails uh not that
they're ultimate protection at the end
of the day uh but they um they allow me
to be fearless and you know I told
Bonino when we were s of talking about
this film I'm like we cannot hold back
um and and we need to also do this film
in a in understated way but at the same
time when people describe what happened
to them we need to hire a couple of FBI
Consultants so our Recreations are
clinically accurate if there's a law
enforcement guy and he's watching this
film let's just say from DHS or
something he's going to go whoa that
would have gone down exactly that way
and that is exactly why you have your
lawyer and accountant standing right off
a camera right now just kidding you solo
that's it continue my friend it's a
pleasure if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell